[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bienvenue pour cette sixième
édition du déjeuner de livres line
business club
aujourd'hui nous avons l'immense plaisir
d'accueillir thierry auriel président de
weston est venu partager ma passion a
grand plaisir
[Musique]
merci c'est très impressionnant passé
avant jean louis debré forcément en tout
cas nous sommes ravis thierry ce que je
propose c'est comme nous l'avons bien
soulevez ensemble pour nous la dimension
humaine est très forte
importante est ce qu'il serait possible
de nous présenter le parcours
professionnel on a déjà vu les n'a donc
on va changer d'école non en collant
dans le timing
non j'ai pas fait l'ena ben là que j'ai
commencé par sciences po et ensuite j'ai
poursuivi sur une voie plus commerciale
qui étaient les sacs dans tout
simplement ce qui est le moment parcours
enfin ma carrière n'a aucun intérêt elle
elle est néanmoins révélatrice d'un
élément donc j'ai commencé par des
grands groupes
car à l'époque et pas tellement le choix
malgré tout j'avais le souhait de faire
un peu de l'entrepreneuriat donc j'ai
fait quelques mois dans une entreprise à
monaco je me suis terriblement ennuyer
donc je suis revenu à des grands groupes
plus structurés entre autres nestlé
ensuite le sia où j'étais directeur
marketing
ce qui est intéressant dans mon parcours
c'est qu'en fait il correspond à la
naissance du secteur du luxe
quand j'étais un quand je suis sortie de
l'essec le luxe n'existaient pas c'était
un secteur pour ne regardais même pas et
pour vous donner une idée il ya deux
personnes qui sont parties dans le luxe
d'un chez cartier et l'autre chez yohji
yamamoto et on les a regardés comme mémé
des extraterrestres va pour nous le luxe
était une série de petites maisons
familiales très prestigieuse mais qui ne
correspondaient pas une perspective
économique quelle qu'elle soit et encore
moins une capacité à former des cadres
supérieurs et est donc après avoir
bourlingué un peu dans ces grands
groupes
j'ai fait ce choix d'accepter d'avoir un
chiffre d'affaires qui correspondait à
mon budget
publicitaire à peu près et de sauter
dans un secteur pour trois raisons
principales en ce qui vous concerne et
d'une part j'étais face à la grande
distribution chez lesieur et donc on
avait une pro activité relativement
limité d'autre part même sur des
entreprises internationales y compris
comme nestlé votre clientèle reste
fondamentalement nationale alors que
dans le luxe vous êtes automatiquement à
l'international puisque vous avez une
clientèle qui est extrêmement nomades
et puis enfin ça c'était plus personnel
j'avais envie de gérer la création
c'était mon moteur à moi et donc je suis
rentré comme ça chez sheva car en termes
de passion semble avoir noté l'art la
musique oui à un mot fait forcément pour
rentrer dans ce type d'entreprises
il faut avoir le goût de la création
chevillée au corps parce que sinon
d'abord sa chair c'est un métier en tant
que tel
donc ça aussi c'est une des composantes
qui est intéressant gère pas un créatif
comme on gère un commercial ou un
directeur du marketing
et puis il faut aimer ces enjeux-là et
croire profondément dans la capacité de
2 to l'aspect créatif a bouleversé une
entreprise et ça rejoint la pro activité
puisque vous voyez d'ailleurs dans le
secteur du luxe et a eu des réussites
époustouflante justement parce que c'est
devenu du coup un véritable secteur
économique est maintenant sur les jeunes
des grandes écoles entre autres ont
tendance à être extrêmement attiré par
secteur la combine forcément pour les
bonnes raisons
oui combien de temps pour pau cette
évolution forte aux le luxe a commencé à
à se construire avant bien sûr que jeune
je 95 ça a commencé en fait dans les
années 80 toujours sur des raisons assez
intéressante en 85 et deux phénomènes
majeurs le dollar ultra valoriser et
donc un apport de cash flow de la part
des américains qui connaissait nos
entreprises de luxe et ça correspondait
aussi au moment où les japonais commencé
à voyager sont un phénomène qu'on a
retrouvé plus tard mais de manière très
différente avec les chinois se sont
intéressés à nos entreprises non par
mimétisme et parce que les entreprises
du luxe pour les japonais sont un des
leviers de compréhension de la culture
occidentale
sinon c'est excessivement compliqué et
du coup ce cash flow a permis de
construire une distribution dans un
premier temps au japon de dinde entraîné
une amélioration de la profitabilité et
puis après il ya eu un cercle vertueux
qui qui s'est mis en place voilà donc
c'est une naissance d'industrie
absolument passionnant oui puis en plus
qui est un fleuron français aujourd'hui
lorsque des grands groupes qui sont
revient sur l'international lorsqu'on
voyage à l'international finalement
on a énormément de d'entreprise
formidable en france mais ce qui est le
plus visible sont effectivement les
entreprises de luxe donc la transition
simple nous allons vers eux jm weston
c'est en fait une histoire complètement
singulière qu'on peut donc découvrir
ensemble boulanger en discutant à ma
table fort sympathique
on s'est aperçu qu'elle ait certaines
personnes qui découvrait que c'était une
entreprise française donc ça vous le
cobra romain est un adepte donc c'est
autre chose mais à romain du client oui
merci
non ce qui est intéressant dans cette
entreprise c'est que c'est
c'est un modèle finalement
d'entrepreneuriat l'entreprise est créée
en 1891 par monsieur blanchard donc ça
s'appelait blanchard père et fils donc
là on est là la france à limoges il faut
savoir qu'à limoges à l'époque c'est
intéressant aussi sur l'évolution de
notre industrie
il y avait environ six mille artisans
ouvriers qui travaillent dans le secteur
de la chaussure
aujourd'hui il n'ya plus que weston et
on et 180 artisans et 200 en tout sur
limoges
il se crée une entreprise de chaussures
et ce qui est intéressant comme toutes
les belles histoires
ça commence par un voyage et une
ouverture à l'extérieur son fils un peu
chahuteurs il l'envoie aux états unis
1904 faut se rendre compte la machine il
n'envoie aux états unis pendant deux ans
pour apprendre
ce qui était à l'époque la spécificité
américaine qui était le cousu goodyear
inventé par les frères gogear et qui se
pratiquait nouvelle angleterre
le gamin passe deux ans il revient
évidemment en france avec toute cette
vision de l'industrie américaine il veut
la mettre en place son père un peu
conservateur et dans n'empêche il est
obligé d'attendre la mort du père et
c'est à partir de ce moment là en fait
il va édicter un certain nombre de
règles sur lequel nous sommes encore
savoir une réduire la production il
passe de 600 par jour 60 par jour pour
privilégier la faune la qualité faire
que de la demi-mesure c'est à dire
aujourd'hui encore on à vingt-et-une
pointures et on va jusqu'à cette largeur
sur certains modèles de voilà d'être
obsessionnelle sur la qualité des cuirs
et d'exercer son métier de chasseur est
chausseur c'est pas rien c'est être
véritablement au pied de ses clients il
ya plus beaucoup d'entreprises qu'ils le
font historiquement c'est intéressant
parce que les deux métiers a qui en
donnait à pourboire c'était les
coiffeurs les chausseurs ce qui ce qui
est quand même un indice du rapport
d'intimité
aujourd'hui est coiffeur ça marche
encore les chaussures beaucoup et à la
suite de ça il l'a il crée sa il change
la marque de blanchard weston et weston
en fait c'était la banlieue weston c'est
une un des quartiers maintenant ça a été
intégré à boston donc c'est un des
c'était une des banlieues dans lequel il
a résidé pendant son séjour aux états
unis et l'intérêt c'est qu'évidemment il
y avait une consonance anglo-saxonne ce
qui est vu ce qui explique bien sûr
cette méprise mais à l'époque l'élégance
masculine était porté par l'angleterre
donc ça a le mérite de porter cette
image là et il change tout il commence à
créer son réseau de distribution parce
que pour chausser il fallait maîtriser
le savoir faire et donc il fallait
savoir son réseau en propre première
boutique courcelles toujours là en 1922
et puis ensuite l'échanger
institué en termes de chiffres donc le
oui entame alors avant on a le nombre
privilège d'être une entreprise
totalement familiale donc porté par une
famille qui est la famille descours et
si j'ai passé rapidement sur les valeurs
de l'entreprise mais si on a sauvé alors
là non pas du tout c'est cette intégrité
là je peux en parler parce qu'encore une
fois je n'y suis pour rien c'est grâce
aussi à l'actionnariat un actionnariat
familial qui construit l'entreprise sur
le long terme
en termes de chiffres on fabrique un
cent mille objets parents jeudi objet
parce que les chaussures il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres choses aussi
on est très franco français pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur généralement
les entreprises de luxe font une
vingtaine de pourcents de chiffre
d'affaires en france dont la moitié est
réalisée par des voyageurs
nous on est quasiment de 65 et 70%
clientèle française donc on est
important en france
encore relativement peu développé à
l'international et on réseau de
boutiques exclusives donc une un peu
plus de 40 boutiques dans le monde
boutique et concessions et on a 180
artisans qui sont tous basés à limoges
voilà à peu près le grand chef de
l'entreprise et les chiffres d'affaires
on peut les apercevoir sur internet
voilà c'est ça donc lors de la
préparation nous avons listé trois
points d'intérêt longs manteaux ont tout
d'abord l'offre est alors j'ai a
beaucoup apprécié ce terme la
désirabilité voile orangé j'ai essayé de
effectivement résumer nos grands enjeux
on est très taille mais je crois je
pense que l'intérêt vous n'êtes pas
forcément dans ce secteur larves
j'espère en tout cas pour certains
intéressés par les chaussures et tant
mieux
mais surtout je pense que l'intérêt
c'est que je puisse répondre à vos
questions parce que ce sera ce sera plus
efficace pour vous l'offre et la
désirabilité oui parce que et sont les
sujets vraiment intéressant en ce moment
parce que tout ça est en train d'évoluer
il y avait quelques shows soeur qu'en
tant que j'étais étudiant on avait en
gros le choix entre une instance mise
qui existaient déjà et puis church et
weston un grosso modo c'est déjà
aujourd'hui ça c'est évidemment très la
concurrence a exposé d'une part parce
qu'il ya toujours les chausseurs
historique
il ya évidemment des chausseurs qui
était ultra confidentiel qui sont
devenus plus présent je pense à berluti
ou à john lobb
vous avez des chausseur tod's qui sont
apparus santoni et puis ensuite vous
avez toutes les marques généralistes et
ça c'est intéressant y compris pour
j'imagine vous business
toutes les marques généralistes qui sont
rendus compte que en ayant une marque
forte
ça vaut pour le service aux s'il est
parfois plus facile de pénétrer des
secteurs de spécialistes c'est un tout
petit peu en train de changer très
clairement vous voyez les remises en
cause de notre système historique et
l'hypermarché actuellement donc il ya
quelques remises en cause et on voit
tout ça est en train de perco les donc
pour nous sont des réflexions
stratégiques que nous avons en
permanence donc un des enjeux c'est de
s'assurer en constamment qu'on ait une
désirabilité qu'on l'a reconstruit c'est
d'autant plus vrai que weston est une
marque historiquement extrêmement
discrète on communique peu
très peu voir et on comptait
principalement sur le fait d'avoir un
produit de qualité irréprochable et un
service impeccable en boutique c'est
toujours le cas alors la qualité et le
service oui mais on considère que c'est
pas tout à fait suffisant et donc on a
une direction artistique moi je crois
beaucoup à la valeur de la créativité
pour rebooster des boîtes
c'est olivier saillard qui est l'ancien
directeur du musée galliera qui est
musée de la mode qui est quelqu'un qui
maîtrise parfaitement les codes de la
mode tout en ayant une certaine distance
avec ce monde là puisque il le connaît
très bien et qui en plus à un réseau et
une un talent qui ai je pas si vous avez
sans doute vu certaines de ses
expositions qui ont marqué dans cette
balance yaga dans cette de lanvin donc
c'est quelqu'un qui a un talent
artistique important dans nos
entreprises de haut de gamme
ça me paraît très compliqué de huy de se
passer d'une d'un élan créatif
après tout un objet de luxe et une
intuition créative qui a appuyé en tout
cas c'est mon approche par une qualité
irréprochable
donc l'enjeu aujourd'hui ce que nous
faisons avec olivier c'est de s'assurer
que les grandes icônes de la marque
pour ceux qui connaissent le 180 le
shass le golf est un site 8 retrouve de
la désirabilité auprès d'une clientèle
qui est plus jeune
le style est redevient
intéressant parce que le style des
chaussures un peu plus pointu un peu
plus effilé est passé on revient à des
choses plus + rendent donc ça ne va très
bien sûr nos iconique et puis bien sûr
il faut en permanence
créer des modèles pour répondre à des
besoins de deux générations plus jeunes
et puis répondre aussi à des usages ce
sur quoi on travaille beaucoup
aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas forcément
répondre à tous les enjeux de mobilité
on parle beaucoup de la trottinette
aujourd'hui qu'un pour ma part on marche
on marche de plus en plus on fait de
plus en plus de vélos y compris pour
aller au boulot temps en temps on prend
et trottinettes d'aidé donc tous ces
parcours la doivent à tout ça doit
s'adapter sachant que notre enjeu c'est
de faire en sorte que mon choses
correctement nos clients pour les
accompagner dans leur mode de vie sont
les chaussures de marcheurs sont pas des
chaussures d'apparat rijkaard il reste
encore de très belles icônes bad sont
revisités commencé alors ben dans le
mocassin ça reste ça reste notre grande
spécialité
c'est à la fois la chaussure quand on
décline le plus en termes de taille de
confort est bon se sentent quand on est
bien chaussée sont des pantoufles
absolue et puis on les décline jusqu'à
d'ailleurs faire énormément de
personnalisation puisqu'on peut
personnel enfin vous pouvez tout
demander ça c'est pas du tout une
commande particulière c'est que moi
c'est un produit tout à fait de
catalogue si je puis dire
mais si vous souhaitez aller en boutique
et choisir votre coeur votre couleur
voilà on peut absolue et les coutures
les semaines absolument tout changer vu
un modèle est extraordinaire comme celui
ci qui le bleu klein pour ça ça fait
partie des des opérations de partenariat
que nous menons on en a mené avec
d'autres que ce soit des maisons comme
les kitsuné ou autre là il se trouve
qu'on avait fait une collaboration qui
était intéressante avec la fondation
yves klein le bleu klein est un bleu
très particulier à obtenir et donc on
travaille beaucoup avec la tanneries du
puy donc en être développé un cuir
spécifique qui reprenait d'ailleurs les
techniques d'impression sur toile de
clinker assez fort assez particulière
l'enjeu là aussi d'apporter de la
vibration à la marque d'aller chercher
une clientèle différente tout comme
roland garros où on est associé avec la
marque la griffe roland garros pour
chaque année avoir un certain nombre
d'opérations avec encore la somme dans
je dirais la partie offre est également
une communication là parlons des
partenariats les attributs de la marque
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui est encore le
plus représentatif les attributs de la
marque c'est ce dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure ses fondamentaux la ne change
pas c'est à dire les rues donc vous à
vivre la mode c'est en fait on
vous restez sur les fondamentaux en
évoluant certaines tendances mais vous
convertissez style
alors d'abord il ya un style whiston
qu'un style on fait entre autres des
chaussures pour femmes mais ça reste des
chaussures très beau riche en fin de de
factures masculine
le tout ce qui est
stiller n'est plus tôt dans une approche
sur le coeur de notre collection assez
intemporel et ça revient plutôt donc
tant mieux mais après on lance beaucoup
de modèles l'an prochain je paye
il ya une trentaine de modèles qui vont
sortir donc il ya constamment un
renouvellement de l'offre qui est
important en terme d' usage en termes de
personnes qui sont des amoureux
historiques comme ça on a plein de
choses à leur proposait donc et puis
c'est important pour
répondre à des usages qui évolue en
permanence d'accord en termes de
communication la party digital
qu'est ce que ça représente ça c'est
aussi un métier qui a considérablement
évolué et qui a un impact énorme pour
l'entreprise quand j'étais dans dans les
grands groupes
en gros ont dépensé 20 % en contenu et
80% on h à l'espace c'était assez
confortable parce que je leur faisais un
film par an sur chaque produit et puis
on était très tranquille et après en
pleuvait en revanche les films en télé
c'était clair les h à 2 h à l'espace
tout ça a été assez normes et
aujourd'hui on n'est plus du tout dans
cette logique là c'est c'est d'abord
c'est excessivement instables ont
produit énormément puisque la durée de
vie de la production à la production
c'est les images c'est une campagne avec
laetitia casta sont des images ça va
très vite et elles deviennent obsolètes
en quelques semaines pour pas dire
quelques jours voire quelques heures
donc le la part de la production est
devenue énorme et ensuite le support la
diversité des supports est devenue là
aussi tout à fait considérable entre
autres avec les réseaux sociaux internet
instagram
j'en passe et des meilleurs avec
énormément de problèmes de sécurité là
je sors d'une campagne de phishing aux
étangs en ligne avec laurent solly sur
ce programme tic là qui sont énormes et
qui demandent en plus de la part des
équipes une réactivité et une capacité
avant à la limite on pouvait perturber
notre relation client mais c'était
c'était de notre responsabilité
aujourd'hui la le lien qui est essentiel
entre la marque et le client peut être
abîmées par des campagnes de fichiers
donc il ya eu un changement majeur et
les investissements entre les supports
traditionnels et les supports digitaux
on est passé de rien sur digital + 50 %
et ça va ça va s'accélérer
sachant que en termes de retour sur
investissement est en
entre autres qui sont dans le retail
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué parce que
la mesure du héros y est difficile la
mesure de l'impact sur le trafic est
difficile parce qu'en ce moment on est
un peu au milieu du gué entre à la fois
un monde qui est en train de changer et
des outils qui sont balbutiant ou mal
adapter ou mal adopté plus tôt par les
équipes donc là on est vraiment dans un
travail de construction complet alors
également des personnalités qui le porte
non les personnalités être sont très
diverses qui est intéressant d'ailleurs
c'est qu'elle se rajeunissent beaucoup
la voyez pas typiquement une jeune femme
qui est à l'oit chaude sauvage qui est
une chanteuse incroyable mais en a ou
franche hausse beaucoup beaucoup de
monde et beaucoup beaucoup de très beaux
voilà on est très fier de ça c'est un
enjeu majeur pour la marque alors un
point important aussi puisque évidemment
c'est un secteur très particulier mais
le positionnement la stratégie digitale
finalement ce sont des préoccupations
qui qui se trouve dans toutes les
entreprises aujourd'hui
quid du système de distribution quelle
est la stratégie à ce niveau là moi j'ai
plutôt tendance à penser que le
l'univers retail dans les boutiques vont
de plus en plus servir de showrooms et
de lieu d'expériences pas très original
et qu'ensuite le digital doit être un
appui pour suivre la relation client en
permanence mais au bout du compte quand
vous avez un client qui fait l'effort de
venir en boutique le coeur de votre
actif il est là et donc vous êtes à ses
pieds clairement et c'est là où vous
devez délivrer le service est créée la
relation et créer la leur relation s'est
pas et je le dis parce que on a tous
fait l'expérience avoir un perroquet qui
vous servent discours de la marque ça on
s'en fout on veut avoir des conseillers
de vente qui exprime parfaitement leurs
personnalités qui vont vous parler de la
chaussure du de la technique du savoir
faire et ça c'est formidable mais qui
vont vous parler de vous avant tout de
votre style de ce que vous souhaitez de
ce que vous attendez et après
le tout l'enjeu du digital c'est comment
vous portez cette relation physique et
vous la suivez par des outils digitaux
je pense qu'il faut pas confondre le les
moyens et le but est malheureusement je
trouve que c'est de temps en temps car
la distribution se fait que quand propre
en direct il n'y a pas de l'or
il ya quelques lieux déjà je vais pas
être perdu dans un magasin de chaussures
donc c'est pas le but donc de temps en
temps je suis chez des multimarques qui
font des marques de mode et donc où là
je suis en je suis dans mon rôle de
chausseurs dans un univers de mode mais
la grande majorité c'est un réseau en
propre avec il ya quelques franchises
nakasai en a une à beyrouth mais sans
des réseaux en propre
là vous voyez là une des dernières
boutiques sont vraiment des lieux
magnifiques moi j'ai été épaté par gérer
le l'aspect esthétique de ces endroits
effectivement des expériences
exceptionnelles et c'est à chaque fois
un designer différent comment vous font
la lasser les champs-elysées qui est
vraiment notre frenchie qui est là pour
pour s'installer pour
nous ancrer encore davantage sur les
champs elysées c'est une boutique qui a
été réalisée que par jeu par joseph
dirand qui doit servir une clientèle qui
elle est ultra internationale et qui
doit à la fois retrouver porté
finalement les valeurs de la marque une
valeur familiale donc vous êtes un peu
chez vous dans une maison ce qui est
intéressant et boutiques weston c'est
que souvent les clients se parlent et un
véritable échange parce qu'il ya un peu
de passion donc ça facilite les choses
et cette boutique est vraiment là pour
cela
on a fait les champs elysées on a aussi
fait on a ouvert après une boutique à
tokyo
ça c'est plus le rayonnement culturel
on a fait une boutique à tokyo sur le
même concept et puis ensuite avec
olivier saillard nos directeurs
artistiques
on a travaillé un concept qui est plus
en plus versatiles plus facile aussi qui
s'adresse à des générations un peu plus
jeunes et qui est dans une logique de
enfin c'est une inspiration ateliers
d'artistes
donc on est allé un peu un peu plus loin
et ça c'est la boutique une autre
boutique qui est à tokyo par exemple on
a ouvert des boutiques plus récemment
entre autres à bordeaux sur cette
thématique à d'accord donc ça c'est
vraiment le point extrêmement important
vu le temps et de manière à laisser la
place à des questions on peut pas finir
sans aborder le côté production on parle
l'auteur des 180 personnes de ce côté
franco français à limoges je propose que
que nous aimions directement sur ce
sujet alors c'est un sujet qui est on a
beaucoup parlé de création la création
par est toujours beau c'est un acte de
séduction et donc c'est le premier
contact avec la marque et c'est le
contact est essentielle je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse vendre un produit qu'avec
du savoir-faire en train jolis produits
et savoir-faire moyen d'un produit moche
avec un savoir-faire formidable ça se
discute donc on met le donc notre savoir
faire il doit être au service d'une
création ou en tout cas d'un style d'une
interprétation
en revanche ce savoir faire pour nous
c'est vraiment la colonne vertébrale de
l'entreprise
parce que c'est un métier très
particulier qui demandent des
savoir-faire très précis je vous cache
pas que fabriqué en france sur des
métiers de cet ordre là ça reste quand
même une croisade
aujourd'hui encore nous arriver à
trouver de nouveaux apprentis ou des
gens qui travaillent beaucoup avec les
compagnons du devoir et du tour de
france
à la fois parce qu'ils sont ils ont
mérite d'apporter un véritable métier
eux
des jeunes et ils ont aussi cette
capacité à transmettre un savoir être
qui nous va très bien
donc on travaille beaucoup avec eux il y
a
combien d'altération qui assure une
chaussure entre 150 et 200 et puis c'est
idiot à dire mais un objet la paire de
chaussures c'est un objet mais c'est
aussi deux deux actes de production
puisqu'en produit quand même c'est dans
la joaillerie vous retrouver la même
pratique c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de réaliser de la marche sur une paire
de boucles d'oreilles que sur une vague
quand vous offrait c'est un cadeau c'est
une paire de boucles d'oreille mais
néanmoins en termes de production sont
deux objets et sur des chaussures
hendaye même les mêmes soucis
donc on j'ai créé l'école des ateliers
weston à mon arrivée où on forme des
personnes sans parcours qualifiants avec
un cercle et de cordonnier à la clé au
bout d'un an de formation il va de soi
que nous on va tenter de garder les
meilleurs on en forme 10 par an à peu
près puis les autres vont aller nourrir
la filière donc ça c'est un premier
point on intègre
des jeunes qui veulent bien réaliser une
des métiers manuels et ça c'est un autre
sujet mais je pourrais vous en parler
des heures sur la pratique politique de
la revalorisation du savoir faire manuel
en france énorme sujet et puis et sur
lequel d'ailleurs ont travaillé à temps
une fondation est très très actifs y
compris avec les compagnons du devoir
puisqu'on a des outils pédagogiques qui
sont développés avec les compagnons du
devoir qui permettent justement de
former les compagnons et surtout de
communiquer pour faire en sorte que des
jeunes puissent s'intéresser à nos
métiers qui est sont peu valorisés en
france sauf quand il ya des émissions et
d'ailleurs c'est très bien parce a fait
job du tip top chef ou là il ya eu un
sursaut de d'intérêt faut créer un top
loose où il ya eu plusieurs il ya
quelques initiatives mais c'est vrai que
après il faut le faire de manière
intelligente et pédagogue parce que
l'enjeu y compris pour compagnons qui
sont saturés dans les métiers de bouche
c'est de gérer la distance qui se crée
entre l'image que la personne a de ces
métiers là lorsqu'il commence sa
formation et la réalité du terrain où
ben oui il faut il faut bosser et tout
ça se construit dans la durée bien
évidemment nous l'avons perdu 12 heures
avec deux boutiques au japon également
qu'elle est le de quoi s'agit-il
cette interaction avec ce pays qui va au
delà de simplement avoir des boutiques
alors il ya plusieurs choses alors
pourquoi le japon nous intéresse déjà
une bonne question
d'abord parce que c'est de loin le pays
le plus avancé dans la mode masculine en
termes de tendances en termes de
compréhension du produit
ils ont très clairement quelques
longueurs d'avancé tourner ça c'est la
première chose pour la mode masculine
la deuxième chose c'est que c'est un
pays qui reste très influent sur
l'ensemble de l'asie voire qui est de
plus en plus influents puisque moi j'ai
commencé à aller au japon au début des
années 90 on ne voyait que des japonais
aujourd'hui vous allez sur l'île zac
efron de champs elysées vous avez des
cars entiers de touristes chinois ce qui
était inenvisageable qui viennent faire
leurs achats au japon à la fois parce
que c'est sûr à la fois parce que
la gastronomie japonaise est incroyable
et parce que les prix sont plus bas
qu'en chine donc ça ses premiers points
deuxième point
et puis il se trouve qu'au japon il ya
une tradition bottière occidental très
forte il ya d'excellents beauté au japon
qui du coup sont nos partenaires et qui
permettent de former des jeunes au japon
donc on fait des échanges que vous
faites un système des changements
actuels d'accord toujours dans le cadre
de la fondation
ce qui veut dire que nous ne
c'est la logique pas d'intégrer ensuite
dans nos équipes il se trouve
qu'actuellement et
on a intégré des personnes qui ont fait
cet échange là mais c'est passé en aucun
cas une obligation on travaille beaucoup
là-dessus
juste après nous avons une image
représentative également de la marque
qu'en est-il tout le monde ne sait pas
cela et c'est quand même là aussi le
chemin d'excellence voit on est plutôt
fier de chaussée la garde républicaine
depuis plusieurs décennies
c'est un client qui est remarquable
remarquable danser
dans ces valeurs dans la proximité que
nous pouvons avoir avec eux ils viennent
de changer d'ailleurs de général
l'ancien était un ancien pilote
d'hélicoptère
damien striby mène à tout voilà c'est ça
un client qui est qui est exigeant et
bienveillant et donc pour nous ça nous
permet aussi de garder un savoir faire
qui le savoir-faire bottier plus tant
que ça et de de travail est un produit
qui est très particulier c'est un vrai
bonheur de siècle ça représente combien
de pères c'est un ordre d'idée
en gros un garde républicaine vous avez
400 chevaux il ya 300 cavaliers dont
quand ils ont deux paires de bottes mais
elle dure très longtemps alors ensemble
la qualité est tant mieux pour moi parce
que c'est ce ne sont pas des sont pas
des business très rentable mais sans et
business à la fois très prestigieux qui
nous aident dans le maintien de notre
savoir faire donc on est très heureux de
collaborer avec eux et c'est une fierté
14 juillet on est tous devant le soit
sur place soit devant noté très bien
m'écouter et du jeu merci infiniment en
tout cas de
c'est pour nous vraiment pas beaucoup on
a tenu le timing on a nous avons bien
recollé et merci beaucoup tiré pour cela
parce que la matière est importante
ce que je propose maintenant laurent tu
en un troisième les manuels micro bon
donnons pas je te passe le micro et puis
n'hésitez pas afin de tenir
nous avons la norme chez mama j'ai une
question
j'ai une question hyper importante que
veut dire le j m
alors est il
voilà exactement parce qu'on entend les
gens martelé jean michel la réalité
c'est qu'on en sait rien paradoxalement
et on a mis des archivistes
sur le coup on est toujours en recherche
le weston c'est hyper coeur je pense que
j aime c'était une manière de deux au
départ le
blanchard le fils blanchard il avait
quand même une intuition marketing
remarquable et je pense qu'il a poussé
le bouchon suffisamment loin pour à la
fois faire croire que la marque était
anglo saxon ce qui n'était pas du tout
le cas et ensuite le jm étaient comme
des initiales qui personnalisé qui
donnait le sentiment d'un artisan qui
était derrière tout cela super cool
comment aujourd'hui on associe jm weston
au made in france
alors voilà c'était un super coup au
départ aujourd'hui c'est c'est un peu
plus compliqué parce que le made in
france c'est vraiment pour nous une
fierté ça l'est d'autant plus que c'est
pas si simple
tant que notre effort soit reconnu nos
clients généralement le savent
et puis c'est à travers la communication
qu'on le fait de plus en plus à voir
d'autant plus qui a tous les attributs
du made in france on utilise principal
je vous ai pas dit parce que sinon on va
mettre des plantes mais on a une
tannerie qui est la dernière tannerie au
monde à faire du tage végétal extra lent
qui est située à 25 km de limoges en
utilise plus de 85% des cuirs français
donc des circuits courts en
remonte entièrement quinze mille paires
de chaussures par an donc il ya une
vraie logique depuis toujours d'ailleurs
de côté très vertueux qui était avant le
côté un peu bourgeois après tout
j'achète j'achète la qualité pour quelle
durée qui aujourd'hui est repris par des
générations plus jeunes sur des
thématiques que on partage en permanence
et à juste titre et auquel on est très
attaché paradoxalement pas suffisamment
parce que la boîte incroyablement
vertueuse là dessus elle le fait pas
suffisamment savoir et et pas
suffisamment de de manière pédagogique
juste une autre question aujourd'hui moi
je vois bien dans les années 80 on
voulait tout savoir notre père de weston
est aujourd'hui la plupart des jeunes
veulent des sneakers qui valent à peu
près d'ailleurs le même prix qu'une
paire de mocassins
comment vous positionner par rapport à
ce marché
c'est ce désir d'une nouvelle génération
alors c c'est intéressant parce que
hélas les nouvelles générations elles
sont comme nous dans nos actes d'achat
elles sont très paradoxale ce sont les
mêmes donc la sneaker est devenue une
chaussure de ville comme une autre très
clairement et on adresse d'ailleurs ce
marché là et on va la dresser de plus en
plus mais les nouvelles générations et
sont dans une logique de
d'acaht sneaker renouveler en permanence
et donc cette génération est celle qui
va vous challenge et étant mieux sur
l'éco-responsabilité et sur le côté
vegan des substituts du cuir ce sur quoi
on travaille aussi énormément et pour
autant c'est elle qui va acheter une
paire de sneakers on s'entraide grand
secret de balancier agac c'est 15 kilos
de plastique et ça vaut 750 euros et
fabriqués en chine avec 17 moule mais et
bravo par balancer kds et en aucun cas
une critique mais c'est pour montrer le
fait que les comportements sont
finalement très paradoxaux et on est
tous pareils dans cette salle très
clairement donc l'enjeu c'est de
d'adresser le marché et de travailler la
sneaker avant il y avait des richelieus
des hawks ward et des mocassins
aujourd'hui on rajoute la basket comme
comme une autre chaussure de vie sont là
non non on a et puis on a des modèles
qui vont qui vont sortir la difficulté
sur ce jeu par l'entrée dans les
éléments techniques c'est que ça ça
entraîne beaucoup d'évolutions dans la
manière dont nous travaillons parce que
généralement des systèmes qu'on appelle
des systèmes sous des noms pas cousue
donc on essaie d'être aussi vertueux sur
les cuirs compliqué d'être vertueux sur
l'aspect parce que la semelle idéalement
vous dites bon bah il suffit de prendre
de l'hévéa
on les a un peu compliqué parce que ça
résiste beaucoup moins bien
et puis aujourd'hui ce qui fait le coup
de l'hévéa c'est en fait l'aéronautique
qui est très consommateur pour ses
trains d'atterrissage et donc on est en
train dans certains cas de dézinguer de
la forêt thaïlandaise parce que le
brésil est saturé de dézinguer de la
forêt thaïlandaise pour cultiver les
verra donc les cette problématique
d'éco-responsabilité elle est très
complexe et en particulier sur la basket
gros sujet bonjour j'avais une question
sur le savoir-faire que vous aviez
évoqué tout à l'heure et sur la main
d'oeuvre qualifiée
vous parlez vous avez la chance d'avoir
180 artisans qui travaillent pour vous
j'ai le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui quand
on parle de main d'oeuvre qualifiée dans
les métiers tels que les vôtres ou
beaucoup de métiers manuels qu'on a en
france
on entend tout de suite parlé on en
entend on entendu avec la reconstruction
notre dame des compagnes et compagnons
du devoir les compagnons du tour de
france est ce que vous n'avez pas le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'il ya un vrai
vide entre les formations
professionnalisantes qu'on a qui sont
proposés dans différents établissements
et
et les compagnons qui sont la qualité
suprême de notre savoir faire et c'est
quoi votre ressenti par rapport aux
formations qui sont proposés dans la
recherche de nouveaux artisans vous avez
mon ressenti principal c'est pas tant
sur les formations c'est sur
l'attractivité du travail manuel en
général les compagnons s'en sortent
mieux que les autres parce que eux-mêmes
étaient très discrets on savait pas très
bien ce que c'était compagnon savait pas
cité des bâtisseurs de cathédrales les
tailleurs de pierre bon il se trouve
qu'il forme à 27 métier dont le génie
climatique donc c'est en est sorti
depuis très longtemps des clichés mais
ils n'ont pas fait savoir et c'est pas
moi qui vais leur jeter la pierre parce
qu'on avait un peu la même problématique
donc je pense que les compagnons il leur
présente une effectivement une catégorie
tout à fait supérieure et qui très
souvent à une capacité de devenir
entrepreneur
moi je ne m'en patron du sinn qui a été
un compagnon pendant très longtemps donc
c'est il ya une capacité d'évolution et
d'ascenseur social qui est forte chez
les compagnons mais lent l'enjeu plus
générale c'est effectivement de faire en
sorte d'attirer sur le métier manuel
mais la formation c'est formidable quand
vous avez tout 1 1
en gros pour la faire courte un artisan
ou un un jeune qui arrive sur un établi
contraint et forcé sa à devenir un
mauvais artisans un artisan qui arrive
avec une volonté d'apprendre son métier
il va devenir bon si un minimum de
compétences ya pas de souci là-dessus
mais qu'est ce qui fait qu'un jeune
arrive un peu à reculons sur un atelier
c'est qu'il n'a pas eu le choix
c'est en gros il a été rejeté par tout
le système l'éducation nationale faut
bien dire les choses il a été rejeté par
souvent sa famille qui même si elle est
issue d'un milieu ouvrier ou de travail
manuel considère qu'elle n'a pas fait
son job de d'ascenseur social
elle a été vue il a été rejeté par ses
copains si tu t'en cas tout un travail à
faire mais d'ailleurs que le maquereau
très bien très bien saisi actuellement
mais ça va mettre des cinq mètres des
années parce qu on est sur un principe
d'éducation et ça met du temps mais la
valorisation et savoir faire manuel si
on veut pas créer des tas de jeunes qui
sont diplômés de diplômes sur lequel ils
n'ont pas trouvé de débouchés il va
falloir
vraiment s'y atteler très fortement
c'est un énorme sujet sinon on va faire
de la frustration où on va vider
d'ailleurs notre pays de tout son savoir
faire industriel 1 parce que on paye
bien chez jm weston
c'est un des enjeux parce que le on est
en concurrence forte
donc on paye oui on paye mieux que les
personnes de la région de limoges est-ce
que je pense que nos artisans sont
suffisamment payés
je préférerais les payer plus d'autant
plus que ce sont des personnes qui on a
très peu de turnover donc sur les
personnes qui ont beaucoup de métiers
exactement d'un jour pour une marque de
luxe comme la vôtre
comment vous expliquer une si faible
présence aux états unis physique on
parlait d'une boutique versus 14 au
japon d'autant plus avec le l'historique
du fils blanchard qui nous t'y je sais
pas quelle quelle explication vous avez
par deux choses - pas trop parler de
luxe parce que maintenant parle
tellement de luxe surtout que on sait
plus très bien ce qu'elle luxe qui est
pas le luxe et le haut de gamme ce nous
ont fait très bien d'autres mais on
considère qu'on fait notre mieux pour
faire
chaussures de la plus belle qualité
possible en tout cas c'est un point de
vue luxe pas luxe le les états unis
c'est un marché c'est un peu comme la
chine vous avez un effet de serre qui
est énorme et donc cgd lapalissade mais
les états unis c'est un marché qui est
grand ça vous pouvez pas être à new york
et à miami comme on est à paris à
bordeaux 1
parce que los angeles new york ses huit
heures de vol que les lois sont
différentes que passe un pays évidemment
fédéral que les contraintes législatives
sont importantes que quand vous êtes un
sur un maul aux etats unis c'est
quasiment 7 jours sur 7 24 sur 24 vous
avez que des contraintes financières qui
sont élevés on est à new york
on a une réflexion sur le développement
sur les états unis
très clairement c'est il faut être très
conscient de des enjeux aux états unis
parce que beaucoup de marques
[Musique]
souffre d'un prolongement de cette
question là parlons des états unis nous
avons entendu les chiffres avec un
positionnement encore très français en
termes de positionnement à
l'international quels sont les autres
cibles que vous visez en priorité déjà
la france parce qu'il ya si si je fais
un sondage là sur le la salle il ya
plein de nouveaux potentiels en tout cas
pour l'instant il ya beaucoup de bons
élèves donc il ya un travail
on a affaire un travail important c'est
de séduction en plus si on se présente
en tant que yvelines business club
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la boutique
champs-elysées alors absolument rien
j'ai désormais un service
nous on a un service parfait mais
peut-être d'ailleurs oui voilà vous pour
remercier son intervention soutenir
toutes les têtes de tous les sujets
auxquels on s'attelle tout simplement
pour une raison simple c'est que je
produis en franges et les marges qui
sont extrêmement faibles
et en plus je vais rajouter une vision
de marque et or c'est que on doit être
très fière de son prix c'est à dire ce
que ça vaut ce et on n'est pas dans un
système justement de tirer vers le bas
c'est une marque qui a toujours essayé
de mais c'est ce pas forcément une bonne
stratégie qui a toujours essayé de faire
au mieux dans chacune des catégories
ce qui veut dire qu'elle arrive avec un
business model qui est compliqué elle
elle choisit les cuire les plus chères
elles là jusqu'à cette largeur en bfr
vous êtes tous des chefs d'entreprise
par rapport à une seule largeur c'est
autre chose
elle fabrique en france sur des circuits
courts donc des tanneries avec des
cheptels français et italiens donc plus
cher donc forcément et en plus de ça sur
les boutiques vous êtes bien reçu et en
plus de ça avec l'obsession de ne pas
encore je suis pour rien donc prenez ça
avec distance de ne pas corriger son
client ce côté cette valeur un peu j'ai
qualifié de bourgeoise mais pas dans le
sens négatif
voilà le d'un bon rapport qualité prix
si je vais être un peu triviale
donc on a si vous comparez d'ailleurs
sur des marques équivalente que je vais
pas citer vous êtes à des niveaux de
prix qui sont beaucoup plus élevés
c'est un business model qui est complexe
et qui et qui forcément dans certains
cas me contre 1 en termes de
distribution parce que je ne peux pas me
permettre d'aller voir un distributeur
il en coûte voilà je t'apprends va faire
ton métier mais tu vas prendre tel
niveau de stock
ta marge plus faible que sur les autres
marques ah oui au fait on fait pas de
sol donc tu veux pas soldés on va pas
reprendre les produits donc là aussi il
ya énormément de contraintes dont il
faut
avoir conscience avec lesquels on doit
jouer et dans certains cas d'ailleurs se
libérer mais en évidemment ça voilà donc
un business model qui est qui est
historiquement complexe et qu'il est
intéressant de travail superbe
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]